[Music]
again I want to thank you all for and
brownie you're doing a heck of a job
FEMA directors working 24/7 CBS FEMA as
well as the hosts of the Michael Brown
radio show Michael Brown
welcome to the Reuben report hey Dave
good to see you good to be with the eggs
you know this is the first time we've
ever done this where we played a ten
second clip let me get do you have any
idea well I can't I can't even imagine
what you might be talking about yes
I've struggled with it for a little
while because I thought do I want to go
right in and throw this right at him
sort of the infamous moment or do we
want to ease into it but then I thought
let's just let's just get it out there
because it it is what it is it's a
seminal moment in my life yet there's
there's before that moment then after
that moment yeah all right there are
many many reasons that I'm glad to be
sitting here with you because I think
we're gonna get into so many of the
things that we talked about on the show
all the time about the role of
government and the difference between
local government and federal government
all of these agencies and red tape and
all that but also that for that moment
and what happened for the months and
probably years after and actually even I
wouldn't I was googling you this morning
all the 10 year anniversary at we're
still pissed on you and all that stuff
it has a lot to do with just sort of the
general outrage culture and blame
culture and all of that so right we're
gonna do a lot here so first let's just
start with that moment though and then
and then I want to do everything else
back sure okay just tell me a little bit
about the days leading up to Hurricane
Katrina I it became clear to me probably
within well it came clear to me the day
after the storm made landfall because I
was on a Black Hawk helicopter with
former senator Mary Landrieu and we were
supposed to be going straight to the
Superdome to meet with mayor Nagin who I
always like to joke is remind people
he's still in federal prison
and in I'm sitting there and I'm not I'm
just kind of reading my notes from my
staff and I look out the helicopter and
I realize that we're going the wrong
direction across Lake Pontchartrain and
I asked the pilot were you going and he
said well the senator has asked that we
go check her cabin before we go to the
Superdome I was livid so now I have a
sitting united state senator next to me
who's just overridden what I said we
need to be doing and what the priorities
are I have the governor sitting next to
her who doesn't have the wherewithal to
say to the senator you know what your
cabin is not our priority the priority
is the people of New Orleans it was a at
that moment that I realized that I had
walked into a state that was so much
more corrupt I've been involved in
politics since I was literally six years
old that it was just so corrupt and it
was so dysfunctional
that I knew that everything that I had
in my hand about how things should
operate we're gonna start going out the
window okay I think that's actually a
perfect story to now start with your
childhood let's just let's just get a
little bio to you because I think that's
really interesting and what led you to
eventually be the director and then
we'll go through everything else right
so just tell me a little bit about
growing up was your family political
what sort of got you into this world Oh
Mike you know my family was kind of
political when I think about it I mean
my mom is 86 87 years old
and she still works for the Election
Board she still does the little local
elections in the little town that I grew
up I think you have to be over 80 to
work at the exactly I think there's a
requirement she's been doing it since
she was in high school but when the
first Republican governor of Oklahoma
was running he was at state party
chairman a guy by the name of Henry
Bellmon was coming out to the Oklahoma
Panhandle and they recruited me at six
years old to be the little kid to hand
to push cards out as he walked these
rural streets of Oklahoma so I just grew
up in this political family that was
always involved and of course you know
involved in student council and you know
in college and young Republicans and all
of that and so politics has just always
been a part of my life yeah and now he
thought I understood politics until I
got to Washington DC
and until hurricane katrina and they
just gave me an entirely different
perspective yeah but anyway long story
short you know I took the typical route
graduate from high school to my my my
wife is my childhood sweetheart her dad
actually delivered me wow that's the
kind of small town we grew up in
Wow we've been married for gosh forty
some years I don't want to say how many
and you know went to law school raised
two children very successful very very
successful children and just had a
pretty normal life except that I knew I
wanted to be a lawyer but I always had
this thought process that you never turn
down and you always look at an
opportunity and if an opportunity looks
good you take that opportunity even if
it's off the path you thought you were
going to take and so that's led me to
these incredible incredible experiences
in my life that most people don't do
because they become lawyers and all they
do is practice law their entire life
yeah That's not me so what was the first
one of those moments when you thought
well there's a good opportunity a little
little to the right off that exit the
home Republican Party came to me and
asked me to run for Congress back in
1988 promised me all of this money that
they were gonna in fact that governor
who was the first Republican governor
went on to be a u.s. senator and then
came back he was a big supporter of me
but I was running Henry Bellmon yeah
former US senator he was involved in the
Panama Canal treaties and everything but
the Oklahoma Republican Party recruited
me and said you know come on we really
want you to run and so I let Eagle get
in the way and I ran against a 12 term
Democrat incumbent in a gerrymandered
district where I got my butt beat but it
was it was an experience that again
most Americans never do most Americans
never throw their hat in the ring and
actually go out and say I'm gonna do it
and I would encourage people whether
it's a city council County Commissioner
state representative whatever it is if
you don't like the way things are going
if you're gonna [ __ ] about I don't
really hear about it unless you're
actually involved doing something
doesn't mean you have to run for office
but you got to be involved yeah it's so
funny after that
that you've been through I guess it's
maybe it's not funny it's either ironic
or perfectly poetic but that still is
your message as someone that you know we
sort of put up as the poster boy for
everything that's wrong with women Dave
let me tell you it may be poetic but it
sorry I quit pointing it's the lawyer it
is I could tell you so many stories
about how dysfunctional state I'm at
I've been involved as a city councilman
I've worked at state legislature as a
finance director didn't you go on I'm
the Undersecretary of Homeland Security
I have seen I have been inside the
bowels of the government and I can tell
you how it works and it is not what most
Americans think yes and we're gonna get
to all of that so the Under Secretary of
Homeland Security that is the director
of FEMA correct that's the gross just
sort of the the more technical term for
that were you involved in the
administration before 9/11 or was it
after the bats when bush no peg you for
no we I was there yeah and in fact I was
in Montana
getting ready to deliver a speech to the
national emergency managers Association
about the role of FEMA in terrorism on
9/11 2001 so you were the director of
him at that time I was I was a general
counsel at that okay and we ended up on
c-135 going back to Andrews Air Force
Base Joe all ba who was the director at
the time immediately went went to ground
zero on that Wednesday morning and I
went to the White House and just spent
the next gosh seems like year just day
in and day out just planning getting
ready for we didn't know what yeah
what's the one thing that really sticks
out in your mind about that day itself
for the first time you you are you're
flying alone there are no planes in the
sky you're flying alone some Airmen
asked me if I want to go down in the
tanker Bay and and just watch as we fly
across you know middle America and I'm
listening on the on the headset and the
only chatter you hear are among the
fighter jets that are flying around the
country and when I landed it was not
knowing it was like there was this blank
wall in front of us
none of us knew what was going to happen
next and so we meet in the Roosevelt
Room in the Situation Room that next
morning to get briefing by the CIA and
everybody else
and I remember just this this quietness
in the room that everybody knew that
none of us knew what we were facing yeah
was there a feeling that George W Bush
was the right guy to handle this because
for all the frustrations that people
right may have with him and that perhaps
you have related to some rug with
Katrina we can get into that right
I do remember at the time and I lived in
New York City at the time so I was there
for 9/11 Roy family was there my grandma
was there my know my dad I do remember
that between George W Bush at the time
but particularly Giuliani I think there
was at least a feeling that these guys
are sort of the right people to be
handling this at the time certainly
Giuliani at least from a New Yorker yes
perspective did you did you feel that
did people feel that within the
government that like that Bush was kind
of able to handle this or have the real
skill set to handle yes it was for me it
was more the most I mean I can still
remember vividly that day in the in the
Roosevelt Room
you've got Tolan Powell you've got
Donald Rumsfeld you've got condi rice
you've got Andy card so you have all
these heavy hitters and here's little
old me sitting at the table too and I
remember watching because I just I'm I'm
an observer of people and I remember
watching all of them and there was none
of the usual because I've been in these
meetings before and there was none of
the usual hey how you do and everybody
was at the table everybody was reading
their briefing everybody was trying to
understand we know that we always
referred to the President as the boss we
know the boss is going to ask some tough
questions and we know we're not gonna
have answers and that's indeed what
happened
you know we had theories we had ideas we
had plans but nobody really knew for
certain Mo's next yeah and especially in
those first few days where we didn't
know if another attack was coming or
what was actually the job of FEMA for
those first few days we are were the
nation's federal first responder we
coordinate all of for example the
Pentagon Ground Zero our job was to make
sure that we had
all of the urban search-and-rescue teams
deployed that we take care of the
firefighters we provide all the
equipment we provide the training we do
all of that stuff so our job was to
clean up Ground Zero our job was at the
Pentagon to help clean that up and what
was fascinating about it was normally
you go to a disaster it's not also a
crime scene but in this case both the
Pentagon and and and in in in
Pennsylvania and obviously in ground
zero
they were also crime scenes so we now
had to coordinate talking about
federalism so now we had to coordinate
you know the federal government state
government local governments and on top
of that we had to coordinate with the
CIA the FBI the NSA and everybody else
who's doing all of the forensic work how
does that go I mean one of the things we
talk about here a lot is sort of the
unwieldy giant government we have right
now sort of all the middlemen and
bureaucrats that get in the way
everything I mean how did it really go
if that's your job here's what's
fascinating when the government's under
pressure like that everybody does what
you have to my mother-in-law had to say
that drill Mike drives my wife like
crazy dude she's now deceased but it was
you know sometimes you just have to do
what you have to do and when when a
crisis hits of that magnitude it's all
hands on the deck and if you need to
break the rules people are willing to
break the rules to make things happen so
I would say that in in those intense
moments that's probably when the
government tends to do the best job
because everybody's trying their hardest
to do what's best for the country yeah
so how soon after that did W tap you to
be the head of FEMA let's see so shortly
after I became the deputy DRI I'd say
like just a couple of months later I
went from general counsel to deputy
director then they announced the
creation of the department well it's a
story about the creation of DHS yeah so
they're gonna create the DHS so W points
me to the transition team or one of five
people putting together the department
and I apologize to the nation for that
because I've got lots of regrets about
DHS I'm happy to die yeah we will
and then soon thereafter Albaugh left
and that's when I became the
undersecretary and the director of FEMA
so probably within gosh a year yeah boy
and then and just just it's the
mailman's story you know you start in
the mailroom and you work your way up
yeah and only two years after that then
the other crisis in years over here
certainly so tell me a little bit about
your regrets creating the Department of
Homeland Security
here's a backstory first that most
people don't know the administration was
opposed to the creation of the
department we thought it was a mistake
we're gonna create this massive
bureaucracy why things are working the
way they're supposed to work but
Congress felt this political desire that
you have to be seen doing something so
once Congress said hey we're gonna move
forward with legislation then the White
House says oh my god now we've got to
get in front of this because we want to
control it and and mold it in our only
view not Congress's view because in
effect they don't want to get
legislation put on his desk
that he they exactly dough and then it's
like these against all right there
exactly so Kay so our job was a great
example of how screwed it is so so I'm
thrown me and four other guys with clay
Johnson the president's best friend
college roommate deputy director of OMB
we're thrown together to create this
massive new bureaucracy by taking 22
different cultures 22 different cultures
22 different organizations and throwing
them in together and trying to make it
work what are a couple of those
organizations that were I mean it's
everybody right well it was secret
Secret Service what the hell Secret
Service doing in Homeland Security the
the Coast Guard the Coast Guard has this
kind of schizophrenic role they've
worked for homeland security yet they're
subjected to the military code of
conduct and they kind of technically
work for the Pentagon so we've got all
of the you've got that you have ice
Customs and Border Patrol immigration
you different grants for the Department
of Justice FEMA everybody had a
different culture and my objection was
you can't throw different cultures
together and really expect them to work
either in the short term in the long
term every organization corporate
private governmental has a culture and
trying to meld those is the one of the
most difficult things to do
look I love carly fiorina consider her a
friend but they brought Carly in to talk
to us about how to do mergers and
acquisitions and I'm thinking wait a
minute
the HP merger and acquisition that
didn't seem to go too well and you're
gonna tell us how to do this twenty-two
government agency thing I mean that's
one objection then the second objection
was you know we got of airports with a
major concern and for whatever reason we
wanted to blame the private contractors
who have a vested interest in making
sure that the airlines are secure right
but that's not good enough
instead let's fire all of them and let's
create this massive new bureaucracy
called the TSA and I'm unlike the kid in
the back of the classroom that keeps
raising his hand and saying but
professor why how's that gonna work but
there was just hadn't what would happen
when you said something like that cuz
now I think in 2018 if you say something
that the TSA most people agree with you
11 unwieldly ridiculous
moderation the reaction was always well
we're gonna meet your objection by doing
why and I had been around the block long
enough to know that that answer was BS
but when you're the one person out of
five you're outvoted so you you tend to
there's a great Washington Post story
that talks about brown as the
bureaucratic in fighter and I was and
the post writes it is if that's a bad
thing and I considered a badge of honor
because I was fighting for just the
reality that when you tell me that
putting these two put these different
agencies together is gonna be budget
neutral that's BS when you tell me
you're going to create TSA but you're
gonna prevent them from ever being a
union that's BS because I just know how
government metastasizes and so the TSA
has turned out to be what I thought it
was the dysfunction within DHS while it
may be minimally better it's still a
dysfunctional organization so let's back
up for a second cuz you mentioned that
before this the security was it all done
by private companies before the TSA
that's almost hard to believe was it was
it all done by private yeah
the airlines who have who has the most
now you think about just trying to
figure out what's the best way to put a
program together well who has the most
interest in making certain that their
planes are never hijacked or flown into
buildings oh the airlines why don't we
let them decide security because what do
they they have competing interests they
want to make sure their planes are
secure their passengers are safe but
that the security operates in the most
efficient and effective way now you tell
me
government's gonna care about those
three things bs yeah well it's also so
interesting because it's like what a
great way to use competition in the
right sense it's like this airline
that's doing it the right way yes where
they could go you know what look at our
marks on security so we're charging you
five dollars more and a lot of people
wouldn't have a problem with it right it
would it would be a beautiful thing I
didn't realize that it was fully private
before that yes Wow any other I mean
that's a well it's a pretty big issue
but any other big regrets related to
yeah well well for example we had within
FEMA what was called the catastrophic
disaster response group everything has
an acronym so was the CDR G and because
the FEMA director under under federal
law when in times of disaster reports
directly to the president you're the
president's representative so this C DRG
when there was a disaster like 9/11 we
brought all the cabinet departments and
agencies together so you usually had the
deputy secretaries there because they
were there on behalf of their bosses and
we would deconflict policy we would set
priorities and if State Department
wanted to do one thing but deal do you
wanted to do another and AG one to do
something else that was where we got all
of those D conflicted because the FEMA
director had the authority of the
president sitting in that room well
that's gone away now and you've thrown
these all together and I've always said
if you want to find out whether a
disaster is being handled properly or
not or any sort of crisis this could be
in the private sector to ask this
question
who's in charge if you can't answer the
question who's in charge then it's a
cluster
is there an inherent sort of there's a
conflict here which is that basically
you're taking government people and for
someone like you that maybe wanted less
government right and I think this is
what you're really saying about Bush at
the beginning of this didn't want this
the image didn't run right but
government and this is the problem with
libertarians in general it's like people
that want less government well if you're
in the government it's hard to look
around the office and be like guys you
know most of us probably shouldn't even
be here
you know we're gonna need new job guys
so in FEMA first started in 1979 under
Jimmy Carter they had a policy of
providing ice to hospitals so that
lactating mothers had a place where they
could keep milk where you could keep
insulin and other medicines that require
pharmaceuticals that require
refrigeration that ice was for hospitals
to provide their local communities a
place for the medicines to say stay cool
and safe and everything else that has
metastasized which is my favorite way of
government it has metastasized now to
we're in a disaster we provide every Tom
Dick and Harry two bags of ice so that
they can keep their hamburger cold or
there or there
clears beer cold and I went to Congress
and said this is out of control we're
spending tens of millions of dollars on
ice
so that a private citizen can keep their
food cold is that really a government
function even talking to conservatives
on the hill let alone Democrats or
liberals or anybody else I was a heretic
because of my movie we can't support
that because that's taking something
away from our constituents well but you
reckon that you realize it's a waste
right
why should we be doing that well we
can't stop it now yeah it's fascinating
and then you just get all these sort of
middle management rats and yeah man no
nobody's gonna give up that right so was
there anything else major between for
you professionally between 9/11 and
Katrina like what were you doing a month
before that was it still we had the ths
related no yes we had the Columbia Space
Shuttle disaster which we had to
coordinate with NASA because NASA was in
shock so we had to help them do all the
search-and-rescue from California to
Texas we had huge wildfires in
California that were just mass
kind of like have they've recently
experienced we had fires throughout the
West flooding in the Midwest we had the
tsunami in Southeast Asia I mean I could
go on and on and on yes my life was just
full of Hell from 9/11 on so until that
until the Katrina moment yes what was
the general feeling about you because
then now we'll get into this where you
were then used as well I was competently
what I was doing the White House always
turned to me to get things done it yeah
okay so I'll take you I'll take your
word but by and large you were thought
of as a competent executive and
everything okay so now now FEMA happens
I love the story that you told right at
the beginning because what a what a
perfect story of like just awful abuse
of power go check out my home right oh
yes you know the disaster areas and all
that kind of stuff how does it how does
it there was a certain amount of time we
knew that this thing was going to be
crazy right I mean how long before what
happened it was gonna be gassy because
we had I had gone to Congress and ask
for an appropriation pot I actually
wanted to spend to the tax money to plan
for 10 truly catastrophic disasters
something like a hurricane your former
New Yorker can you imagine category 5
going up the Hudson River
can you imagine something happening to
the LNG natural gas port in Boston a
terrorist incident there imagine the big
one hitting California or the New Madrid
fault imagine because New Orleans a
fishbowl a category 5 filling up New
Orleans so Congress had given me money
to start doing catastrophic planning for
these kinds of things New Orleans was
the first one we picked and when we did
a tabletop exercise to see if we could
coordinate the response the tabletop
exercise fell apart Dave so I knew
probably nine twelve months before
Katrina actually occurred that we
weren't ready so what does that actually
mean when you're doing a tabletop
exercise that that's just coordinating
all yes you know all the players in the
room and you pretend like you're going
through a disaster so what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are the conflicts how do we
deconflict all these policy issues do we
have enough food
how do we get DoD to does dld have
enough equipment on hand to get in food
supplies and everything else you
exercise that around the table and
Louisiana fell apart yeah wouldn't work
was it right at the beginning of it that
you realized how severe it was I've been
criticized because in May of 2005 I had
my wife this is before for visiting for
Katrina in May of 2005 several friends
of mine including Colin Powell had said
you know what it's probably time to
leave and I I asked them seriously why
is it well you've done everything that
you can do in terms of trying to mold
DHS into what you think it should be and
nothing else is going to happen it is
what it is that you have you have fought
the good fight you've been here six
years
you know and of course my wife was weak
it's time to go back to Colorado let's
go back to Colorado and so I told an
e-card the White House chief of staff
in May of o-5 that I wanted to resign
and go back to Colorado and what
typically happens and II said can you
wait till Labor Day and go through one
more hurricane season for us and that'll
give us time to find a replacement now
when the president asks you to stay for
five more months sure I can do that man
Labor Day what was the date Katrina hit
it was on this night August 20 at Labor
Day you know whatever it is separate
days later yes okay so so it hits I mean
I can remember watching everything on
CNN at the time you mentioned Nagin who
is the mayor of the mayor of North
Lawrence how chaotic was it to
coordinate before you after you said
this this initial test had failed about
a year before it was it was virtually
impossible
so I land at the Superdome and the
Superdome well let's go back a step
yeah before I actually went to New
Orleans before the storm made landfall
max Mayfield who was the director of the
National Hurricane Center fellow okie he
and I got on the phone together and we
knew how bad the storm was going to be
but we could not
get the attention of state officials and
frankly we couldn't get the attention of
of the DoD and State Department other
people that would be playing the role
how is that possible you now have this
new DHS that was supposed to be quell
exactly later well because who's in
charge
I remember who's in charge well
everybody is now competing for their
pecking order because of DHS so I tell
max Mayfield would you please explain
because I'm gonna have bushes and
Crawford he'll be on the civets call
this top-secret phone conference video
and everything and I'll have the mayor
the governor of all the Gulf states
there Jeb will be there for Florida and
I need you to read them the riot act
about how bad this is going to be and he
did and then I pulled out an engineering
report that said the New Orleans
Superdome cannot even withstand a
category 3 based upon engineering
reports and the mayor just announced
that he's going to use the Superdome as
a shelter of last resort I'm screaming
on this call you can't do that that's a
huge mistake blah blah blah at this
point what did what category did they
think it was gonna be we thought it's
gonna be a 5 yeah it when it actually
hit it was a 3 but as we all know it
still ripped off the roof of the
Superdome so I knew going in it was
going to be bad I say all that to lead
to this one point the day that I'm
leaving to fly to Baton Rouge I remember
exactly where I was as I'm 195 one
around the Pentagon and I called Joe
Hagin the deputy chief of staff to tell
him that I'm headed to Andrews I'm going
down we're doing everything we can and I
said Joe but this is gonna be a cluster
because I can't get stuff coordinated
now and the storm hasn't even hit and
because I had already told them I wanted
to leave I said in an email to Hagin hey
can I quit now and of course everybody
picks that up
oh.what Brown doesn't care he's he wants
to quit before the storm hits that's
fascinating I mean I remember that yeah
sure I remember the hill and you were
just being sarcastic I'm a sarcastic guy
yeah I'm a total on the smart ass yeah
and so I had already agreed to stay
through Labor Day I
I was walking into a buzz saw and I'm
telling Hagen hey can I quit now and of
course the New York Times you know for
years all of my emails they see the
jokes that I crack because let me taste
them today not to get off the subject
you know but when when people are
suffering and people that are the rescue
workers the firefighters that are taking
people off roofs that are taking them
out of flooded homes they're working
their asses off they're tired they're
worn out they're stressed out you know
what the best thing to do is give him a
little humor yeah show him so you can
show a little humanity it's my
father-in-law was a schmuck I told you
delivered me as a surgeon he used to
talk about how he would relieve stress
in the o.r by cracking jokes and I've
always thought that the best way to
manage people in a time of stress is to
remind them of their humanity make them
laugh and if they can laugh for five
seconds
that gets the endorphins running and
they can go out and keep working 24
hours a day seven days a week and I was
criticized for joking well you know what
screw because I've been asked before
well would you take any of those emails
back not a one of them because you know
what that made a staffer smile that made
somebody laugh and if you don't
understand the context and method within
which it was made then you are
deliberately just trying to make hay out
of something
[Music]
you